well um i'm disappointed that people
show up late and uh we're gonna
try to do some
knuckle slapping when they get in here
but uh meanwhile
uh let's get let's get started the first
thing i wanted to do is clean up
something that we that we uh uh
talked about
oh two weeks ago
just uh uh just because just to um
sort of tidy up that little part of the
work
uh namely to to have a good
uh to figure out a good algorithm
for the problem given a set of a set of
inputs zeros and ones what
uh faults does it detect
so this this problem what's the
uh what's the best way to do that
and i'm looking for a bottom-up method i
mean a method that that starts out with
a
that goes through the circuit uh sort of
one pass through this dag and come and
at the end you know which faults um are
detected does any anyone want to
describe their
their method for this you know
do you have the evaluation already or do
you know we just got the the inputs i i
just got x's you know in other words i
know i know the uh i i i i can evaluate
it as i go but i you know so i start out
with
knowing what x1 to x7 and y1 to y7 are
in this in our in our multiplier
and then and then every time i go to a
gate i want to do some computation
that
that
essentially reflects that
if this gate were an output
how many um
stuck at faults
would would those inputs have detected
for at this output okay
you see the see the problem i'm i'm
asking uh
uh
if you can take a you can take a uh
a dag and cut it at any point and say
just consider all the gates less than or
equal to k
and and uh then those that uh and
and now for each of these for each of
these gates that
um
one k we can imagine that it's a it's a
it's a it's an output of the uh of the
network and if that were an output or
i'll just choose any one of them as
output if that were an output what stuck
at false um
would be would be detected so take a
take a simple very simple circuit
where you've got
just just one gate say it's an and gate
and suppose x and y are
zero and one
okay what what's stuck at faults do we
detect at this well maybe i better make
the trick a little bit
a little bit more interesting
so we might as well um
do an
exclusive or and then an or say
okay so now suppose that we just give
some some pattern to these x y and z
um
and we and we say what what's stuck at
faults uh would would be detected well
first of all in the first case if if uh
if i have x and y
and i and and i would detect it if of
course i'm comparing the true value to
the uh uh to uh to the stuck at value
so we've got three gates um
g1 g2 g3 let's say
and at g1 what's the
situation
okay so since this is zero and this is
one we get a zero since this is zero and
this is one we get a one
here and here we get a a one
and so if if uh
if this one is stuck at one if gate one
is stuck at one then we would certainly
detect the phone
um
no no i'm just saying
you wouldn't detect i was talking of the
level above you
oh i think he's saying it's an output
yes
yes
if
the if the output of g1 is an output if
the output of g1 is an output then you
would detect the second one on
x oh i'm not considering x to be yeah
x is never stuck at anything but yeah
so so uh
so i have a set up so there's got to be
a set um let's say s1
is going to be the set of um
the set of uh gates uh the set of stuck
at faults that would that would be
detected by x by zero one one um if if
g1 were an output
and i'm and i'm saying that that's g
g one
sticky stuck out
would be the only will be the only one
that we that we detect
and s2
is uh well this is too it's too easy
because uh
that has only
one gate
so it's too trivial to to be
considered but now s3
is what now see so this
uh s3 says stuck at um okay well
certainly g3 stuck at
zero would be
would be one case
but what about
others
the g2 is sticking one
sorry
g2 stuck at zero
yeah it would have to be some subset of
the input i mean it has to be in those
two sets it either has to be this gate
itself or it has to be one of those in
the gates
in in the gates before it
um
that
that occurs here so it's kind of so so
what about g1 stuck at one
um
no because it's not present because that
one gets it that one gets masked by the
one here but g2 stuck at zero uh would
not be masked by that so so we pick up
one of them
so we pick up one of them now my claim
is that there's a way to compute these
sets
um
as we get just like you compute the uh
the values of a day as a you know in a
procedure that i call bottom up although
it seems to be going downward on the
button
procedure from the inputs to the output
uh
there's a
there's a top down procedure the
converse procedure
that we
that we observed the
other time well no
well we had a theory we had a theorem
that said that uh that uh
if this final circuit
um
if we would if we would uh
that would involve say g2
um
if and only if
the the the value of f g3 expressed in
the terms of x's was going to be g2
times
f of
times some some function that's f1 of
xyz
plus
f2 of
xyz these are
where we would expand the function
uh we we would expand this function um
down into the original values x y and z
except when we got to g two we wouldn't
further expand g2 and we reduce
all ands and rs and exclusive os2
polynomials in in
plus and times
and if and only if f1 was equal to one
which
was was g2 a a
a stuck at uh fault for
for this well now um
uh but maybe you since nobody answered
the original question so
so readily maybe you don't have the same
maybe you have a different way of of
computing these
these things i mean
somewhere along the line you you
probably have to have in your program
a solution to this problem maybe not
i've been kind of concerned about one
problem that comes up
i don't know if it's taken care of in
your method or not i was just trying to
look at a little example
where
if you assume that you do have a stuck
at fault at one gate
and that gate has many outputs and
propagates sort of a part
that later the combination
of
um
the faults on many lines will come back
together to give the writers
yeah so so you so two wrongs make a
right or something like that
as they say
okay uh yeah this would be this will
have to be detected in here that
sometimes you you might have a case for
example that
that um
something is
that that both inputs to an exclusive or
uh would be affected by a stuck at fault
for example yeah
this should come out of our if we if we
get a if we get a
an algebraic rule for how to how to
calculate s3
goes down to input on s1 and s2
then
that should solve that problem and it's
an important problem
at least it worried me for a long time
so the function would have something to
do
right so let's let's take a for example
for any or gate suppose we have an or
gate here and this is um
and and uh the or gate is g sub n
and it has a it has its inputs g sub i
and g of j
now i want to calculate s of s of n
in terms of s of i and s of j
and the s's for the inputs are zero
these are empty the empty set here s
s is equal to the empty set on the top
row for any of the inputs so i can
assume that these are gates
okay what's the formula for
for uh
for this and i'll give you a hint that
there's there's one that i know is
always in there
um uh we can also use the values so
let's call it v sub i v sub j
and v sub n is the value of the gate
v sub n being equal to
w sub i or there's all these v's on the
board here that's been a new symbol for
or another another word for value
well certainly that gates itself
complemented value yeah yeah so
then
with the with the v sub n bar with the
opposite value of b sub n bar that would
certainly be a a fault that we would
detect
um if it were stuck at their own value
okay
and then one
yeah and now now see what we did here we
somehow picked up
s2
and not s1
yeah you get
you get the guys in s
give the guys an s2 because the other
one is uh
zero
cj times teacher okay
so you have something like
union
vj
if cj friendly jail
yeah okay so you've seen it we've got
use apl
right
okay so so we have um
uh
well there's various uh there's all
kinds of uh
ways of notation so
i have to just choose one at random so
then we say s sub
s sub i if
uh
is not v j
if not v j
okay so if not if v j equals 0 if
okay so now we've got very we've got
some competing
comments on the floor here but i got to
write something down before we can we
can
now somebody said what about just sub
sub i minus sj the ones that are in
sight and not sj
um
vj is
zero so this is uh
uh anyway some formula like this seems
to be it seems to be involved and we
should we should be able to work out
what it is so
if v j is zero
then
then that that means that we're taking
an r of zero with something that
that we had as a
as a um it's not that fault that was
recognized for recognizable here
and the value
is coming through
down here so it looks as though you
don't have to be
uh it looks as though we ought to be
able to detect that stuck at fault also
after g sub n and similarly by symmetry
this this case here but why did you say
s sub i minus s sub j basically to call
the the fault that uh karen was talking
about supposing the same fault is
propagating down from right over both
sides or both of these are
there yeah
in that case uh no no you have to know
it what i mean by v sub j
v sub j means the correct value yeah
that's right without false yeah so uh
here
v sub g may be zero but if the fault is
coming down
through through ga2
then
under that fault condition v v sub j
would be one right
in which case the fault could not
propagate through
my next one that would be right right
if g n were an x are then we would have
then we would have probably a different
situation in our right i think so but we
we'd like to have a formal
so so at least
saying is that so
some gate some some stuck i thought this
is is missing is detected both in in
both of these places
that mean that and that vj is zero
so that means that really the value
coming through here with the fault
is one on this side and it's wrong on
this side
so then the value that comes through on
here
is going to be always one
and so he's thinking that that
that uh it's not that we're not
detecting the fault
it's not necessarily detecting we're not
necessarily detecting the fault yeah so
in what case are we so so we're getting
a one at g n
and uh we're detecting a fall only if
the true value should have been zero so
the true value should have been zero
assuming that b j is zero if and only if
this one was zero
okay which but we have the wrong value
on this guy so the one is here so we're
i think we're okay the true value of
this one then would be zero and so and
so we so i think this formula is correct
yeah yeah yeah well let's uh let's prove
it let's prove it algebraically
um
by erasing this
but uh thank you for your courage
because i'm maybe there was somebody
that didn't follow it either
okay i mean um sorry's objection was
that if if um
uh
if you had a
politics objection i didn't follow the
intervention i didn't follow my oh okay
i think it doesn't it doesn't matter
because uh uh we would pick it up if the
true value of g sub n is zero
because we're getting g sub n equals one
under those hypotheses
and if the true value is zero then we
then we are detecting the fault
it becomes that one
the problem is if the true value of g
sub n is one and it's created by one of
v i and v j being zero and the other
being one because if some
fault is causing
it's kind of showing up in both gi and
gj then it's just going to switch the
one and the zero it's not going to
change the output of
g sub n okay so you're saying that um
that
my conclusive proof was it was was was
also false
i said correctly okay so you're saying
we have a case of a zero and a one let's
say a one and a zero
um
inputs uh to the thing uh and both of
these are are nearer because both
because
they're both uh carrying a certain a
certain fault along in them and and it's
detected so some gate back there made a
mistake and and it's been picked up by
both of these
all right now
what uh
so you're saying that uh
these are the true values the actual
values are going to be 0 and 1 and
therefore we're coming through with a 1
at the output
and
that also looks convincing though
what happened to my argument okay so um
so now
you're saying that
that then the values that we find here
are one and zero
and we come through
and take the or and and we still get a
one so so it seems like you're taking
that
set s in and then taking the difference
of the ones which are in there
so look at all four cases
okay so you've got a zero and a one
and then sometimes if somebody is
involved
is in both of the sets
um
that guy
because he's visible on both the sets
he's actually changed the values yeah so
it's just like again exactly yeah
and and so it still comes out to a one
at the bottom
yeah okay let's
let's let's use the algebra instead
what i mean is that we've got some big g
and g sub i
is equal to g
of uh plus um
zero or one
when we when we when we write it as
polynomials in the inputs
g sub i is equal is is expressed as
well equal to my previous notation it's
equal to g f1
of x
of the inputs
i'll suppress the inputs that means all
the inputs here
plus f2
so we've written it as a polynomial
modulo 2
and f1 is known to be one if you assume
to be one
if g is in the set
of the of the faults there
and um f2 could be it is either zero or
one so f1 is equal to one that f2 is
either zero or one so so
so expressed in terms of these inputs i
i could say that gi
is equal to g
plus z over one
similarly g j
is equal to g
plus c over one
oh well let's see
oh i'm fine that's in the case that
they're both that's in both sets so a
little confused as to what these small
g's are representing okay
let's uh
uh
okay i imagine that that the g is any k
less than or equal to n no less than n
and then i and
and i when i write g sub n
and i want to write g sub n
is equal to uh
is equal to g times
f one of the inputs
um
plus f two of the inputs
okay
and i mean i want to i want to imagine
that i have that i've done this
algebraic calculation where g is the
previous gate
and and i don't expand g to its inputs
but everything else in this in the
circuit i expand out to its inputs
so i imagine
uh taking the the network at g n and
every time i have a gate i replace it by
its inputs unless the k is g in which
case i just stop dead essentially i get
a polynomial in all the inputs
okay now
the question is what is f1 and f2
so i don't like this notation
let me call it fn
and hm
so that i so that i got a better
notation to current with
gi
was equal to g times f y plus a psi
gj
is is g times f j plus h k
some some
gate
i mean
little g is any is any
gay
and we can imagine that we've already
computed the f5s and have j
so they're now
um what is what is that what are fn and
hn
um
according to uh if we ask if we have an
or gate there well um that's g f i
plus h i
or
g
f j plus h j
so we have to reduce this or to a
polynomial modulo 2. or is the hardest
case plus and times are easy
so
the lowercase
is
is the
complement of the and of the complement
like by t-morgan spain's law this
extra line there
okay and the complement is obtained by
adding one
so
polynomially
this equal to
this
um
so i know from this i should be able to
determine
f n and h n so we write this out
g
squared is equal to g
in modulo 2 x squared is is equal to x
so we have g times
f by
uh fj
plus hj
plus one
um
is that term then
then uh here we get an h
sorry this is an f i h j
let's go find
we need f
truck oh sorry
okay and the next one is f j
h
h i
plus f j
okay and then and then the other terms
are h i h j
plus one and so on h i plus one
h j plus one
plus one
so otherwise this is f n
and this is hn
in this in this case hn is actually the
or of the two h's
and this is uh
um
something depending on the f's and the
h's it looks like uh
if i if i rewrite this
um
i should probably know more boolean
algebra but um
i have to stick to this part of the
board so i'm going to now go up up here
and rewrite it what do we get well the
it's a coefficient of g is that but then
the bottom one is the complement of h i
times the complement of h j complement
so that's a hi
or hj
and
and then
what about this one well the same kind
of a thing seems to be here the f i f j
f by f j is f i or f j
um and then there's plus h i
f a f j plus h j f i
okay so now let's see what are the h's
are the h's the same as the value of the
gate
is is h
is is is it true that h
h sub n is equal to v sub n
and h i
is that depends on g
does it if g is supposed to be zero
c see g is any gate
yeah
if g is a gate that's supposed to be
zero yeah if g is a gate that's supposed
to be one
and it certainly
won't be you know
but
i think i'm more i think i computed this
right um
let's see
i'm trying to uh
get out of the rule for calculating h in
a f and h
for for and i think i did it right for
an or gate so let's do it for an and
gate so for an and gate i have gfi
plus hi
ended with gfj
plus hj and this is equal to g
f by f j
plus h i f j
with h j of y
plus h i h j
and in the other cases gfi
plus h i
plus g of j
plus h j
and this is equal to g times f i plus h
f j
plus h i plus h j
so in each case
um the
the constants are here the the thing
that doesn't depend on g
is the uh
uh is obtained just by using the
ordinary gate uh rule
and so by induction this should equal v
sub
should equal v sub i
can i make a
fundamental error here
maybe we've proved that zero equals one
we've always waited
i mean a lot of correlations
okay
yeah okay well let me see so so i got to
i got to uh
so so g n is a function of the input and
we can express it
in this way and and if it's true value
is always equal to h
h sub n
then
that seems to be contradictory
now it's not because i mean if
if your f n happens to be one and you're
the gate that you're
that's hidden way back in the works that
you're detecting the fault at
is supposed to be producing one then gfn
is going to be one and so g sub n is
going to be
say
yeah if this is
if
if g is if if that gate is supposed to
be producing a one
and if that time is one
then we're then we seem to be picking up
the uh
the wrong value so think so what's the
com what so uh there should be a
an easy counter example and i'm sorry i
got i shouldn't be wasting so much time
this is x suppose that i have a
um then a simple case where
where i've expressed uh
g
is my first gate in the system so so
let's say g1 is equal to
is equal to g1
little g will be g1 and i'll just say g1
is equal to d1 now g2
will then be
um
oh
that's where that's where my induction
breaks down right there
at level
g
when i
when i is the value that
that corresponds to this little little g
here
then h i is not v sub i
except for that uh h i was going to give
me 0 okay so the same calculation works
on the h's as works for the
as as
as for the v's except at
at g itself where it's always zero okay
that's
that's where my
where i slipped okay
now back to where we were then this is a
a rule for calculating
the set of uh naming the values
for which this is equal to one
um
are it will give us the set of values uh
for
the um
for the gate and it means that the h is
so a rule like this um
should
should be derivable from this formula so
let's take a look at it closely
um
maybe it simplifies down but here's what
here's what it tells us we want us we
want to say when
uh when is this coefficient equal to one
and um
so uh
we know the set of gates we know
uh let's see
we know what fi and fj are
based on the
on the s's
for um
for the inputs
namely
uh f i is is one if and only if g is an
element of
of si
what we don't know the h
we don't know the h is
uh well we started we took we started
doing all the h's yeah
okay
so it looks like my algebra isn't doing
much better than my uh than my
directory
reasoning from cases
um
so let's get so so we we have to
consider various cases that
that
f i
is equal to one
in that case
then we know that gi is equal to g plus
h i
um
and the value
and the value of v sub i is equal to g
plus
plus h i
um
and um
that's weird because it depends on
it depends on the true value of the gate
in question
um
this this says that g is an element of s
sub i
and
and so we want to
um
if h i is
okay
what is s
in terms of the s mode s
let's divide yeah s and i is equal to
the set of all
g
such that
um g sub n
equals g
instead of all n
plus h so yeah see h sub n is not a it
is actually a function of um
it's a function of g
i mean this
this th these f's and a and
and
and h's are specific to choice of choice
of a certain gate for every for every
little g
fixed here you i get a set of i get a f
j and h
you know the h this whole confusion is
there's the g written represents the
gate and there's the g that represents
the output of that cage
i mean probably need another subscript
in there someplace
yeah one of the main rules of technical
exposition is to try to avoid
subscripts when you can but
sometimes uh
uh the
the identification of values without
subscripts is also
is worse huh um
but this adding a subscript trap is what
you're trying to avoid
okay so let's see h depends on g in the
sense that i have
that if i had another if i if i was
expanding with respect to another gate i
would have wound up with a different
remainder h
okay
it's very confusing without specifying
that dependence
it's what it's very confusing without
specifying
yeah right so so that's fn
that's good
i like that
all right and now we've got we've got
our recurrence formula
that says
uh i mean these two formulas that i
think are correct and uh and then we
should
maybe see that the whole thing
simplifies later
um
uh the the uh
let's see uh namely f
n
fnk was equal to
f i k
or
f j k
plus
h i k
f j k
plus
h j k f right here
and then we had on the case and h n k
was equal to
um
the
f
uh yeah this yeah f um
uh um i k h i k
or h j k
and this this rule holds for if n is
greater than k
so
practice all this by n
greater than k
dependence of
is
less than k
then
f is
is
zero and h is well
n is unequal to k
anyway we know that
now if we have an and gate
um
f and k was the same formula but with n
instead of
exactly the same
so i don't have to write anything
h and k is h i k
n with h j k
and the plus case
f n k
was equal to f i k
plus
f j k
period
and
h and k was equal to h i k
plus
h j k
so that's the case of n unequally k
when n is equal to k
you have fk
equals one and hkk equals zero
and that's
that's the way you expand the gate in
terms of itself g k equal to k
and and so we have this way of
calculating
on an input
the case of an input the x zero and the
inches are the value of the input
you can probably try expressing that
that survives in terms of that
so essence the s is a set of all k's for
which um
for which f of
i k
is equal to one
uh
now i changed the s a little bit before
i
i i had a gate in there and i said it
was a gate stuck at a certain value
now we can we can always say that a gate
is in there stuck at the wrong value
there's a certain value of v sub k
so it's really
according to our other notation it was
the set of all g sub k
uh v k bar
the opposite value for
capital t
yeah did i have capital g
okay well i want capital g to represent
the game and
if you represent the formula for the
gate
all right
okay so we have this
we now have the capitalistic theory of
of uh
our thoughts yeah now all we have to do
is uh
is to work out the bottom up way to
calculate see if we can simplify it now
let's see correct i thought that this
was all going to be so simple and like
and
um
but it's it's sort of uh
like like if we're gonna very if you
might ramsey grades your problems he's
gonna he's gonna at least have to have a
routine like this to see if you've
really covered the false you claimed
so somebody has to know a way to
there ought to be a relation between h k
and v k
i guess it's obvious
because you plug in
i mean like v sub n will have to be
equal to g
v sub k
times uh f n k h
so
so that's the
so there is a formula
um
that we can compute v
and knowing v k
and
f n k and h and k well actually you have
you have a v sub n is equal to v sub k
times f n k yeah yeah i think so so the
so now g sub n is either zero or one so
like the g sub minus the same as v sub n
yeah
all right so we might as well just use
that notation
so so that so that's the so those are
the values of the of the gates the uh
let's say g sub n now is the value of
gate n the the true value of gate n
right so these folks so well this
formula
holds for all n
and this this gives us a way of
calculating the fs and gs recursively
from the bottom instead of going from
the top
i mean going from the inputs to outputs
instead of going from output stream
um and uh
so uh it looks as though
um
it's it's that that the the matter of
which to throw
what k's to throw in here
in order to get the x equals one it's
going to depend on
knowing the
knowing me so so let's expand that out
and see if that simplifies
well i'm
just going to go back to
um so g sub n was equal to g sub k times
f
n k plus h nk
and now um
i wanted to get the i want to i want to
rewrite this formula
and see if it simplifies so f n k
is equal to f by k
or f j k
plus
now here's f j k
times h i k well h i k we
get from that formula g i
plus
g k
f i k
ah this is gonna this is gonna work
plus f i k i think
times g i
uh gj plus gk fjk i'm just plugging in
for
for um you know for h i
k here in this
in this formula h i k i i could use a
minus sign but minus and plus are
the same
module two so so uh
uh
now what do we notice
coming out here
mine cancel
yeah these terms cancel with each other
so
so uh therefore i can replace the the h
by a g here
h i
and
gj
and then the same thing here
so it only depends on the values of what
we used to call books
g survive
b subjects it only depends on the values
that the v's that we had before and so
that gives us a rule then to get the in
our gate situation it says that you that
you have the the
the uh uh
the the union of the two of the two
previous sets
uh except you take out um the sets that
are in
s k if gj is one
and you put back any and you take out
this
um
the sets of uh
s
i if if gj is one
and take out really means complement the
the state itself
so there so you can compute then
based on
on
the values of i and j
and the previous sets you can compute
which of the uh which of the things
going in which go out
so so it's a sort of a venn diagram
situation you have si here
sj here
and uh
this
and uh s i is the cases where the f i k
is one
um
so so if you consider the
the case of s i
sorry
s i
s j so you got we got elements that
aren't
that aren't in either s i r s j elements
outside
for that if both f's are zero
and uh and this whole term is zero okay
uh we have the case where ed where where
fy
where the element is in si
and it's not in sj if it's if so so if
it's if it's recognized by the i input
not today input that means that f i is
one
and f j is zero so we get a one here
and i get a zero here
and i get um
uh gj
there
and so
uh the thing is in
um
uh
so so we use s i minus sj
if
um
uh the elements of s i minus sj if uh um
v
or v sub uh or g i guess we might will
say
if g sub uh
um
j is zero
and s j minus s i
if g sub i equals zero
and s i intersect that's j the
the things that are common to both those
both have
those have f
all f's are equal to one so we get one
here plus g i plus gj
and this is if
gi
plus gj
is equal to zero
so either they're both so so in the case
so the the interesting thing then about
an or gate
is that if if the if there's a stuck at
fault that that appears on both of the
inputs to the r gate
if that stuck at fog gets through
only if the values on the two legs of
the or gate are unequal
you have a one one or a zero one um i'm
sorry not equal yeah if you have a zero
a one one or a zero one coming through
an or gate then the uh then then you
pick it up the stuck at fault
uh of the bottom of the or gate but if
you have a zero one and a one or a one
zero you don't
that's the that's the solution to the to
the uh
to hardly how to merge them in case of
rs
and um
the case of anne's will be similar
uh except that
um
we don't
we i think we omit the first two cases
here
and and the and the case of pl or the
exclusive r is easy because you just
take the exclusive or the two sets
okay well long algebra a long time
that's uh
unless we have a question on this uh
you'll all be clear when you read the
notes in case it isn't immediately clear
now
essentially all
i mean what this means is simply that
you divide the inputs into those which
will give you one those which will give
you zero and if the complements of the
inputs are on the opposite side of the
cam then the fault will get through
uh given that both it's coming in on
both sides if it's on the same side it
won't get through yeah that's not that's
a uh maybe that would have saved us 30
minutes to
sing that i don't know
i always i'm reassured by algebra
although it it
you know it's a there's a difference
between me and other people and
sometimes i like to to do something in a
different mode where i don't understand
what i'm doing except algebra and it
still gives me some something that i can
interpret in the real world that gives
me some confidence
okay now the other thing
on my agenda for today
was to uh i was to talk about uh
covering
problems
and uh now that
the the covering problem for the half
bad circuit is
is presented in this little chart
uh and the one in in the circuit that we
have really for the problem
is a little different because
uh in the real problem we have uh 65 536
rows
and 802 columns
so
uh now in the real problem
uh we observed on tuesday that one of
the columns has no x's in it the x means
that uh this input will detect this
this uh fault
and um and we in one of the columns had
had no x's in it at all so there was no
way to detect that particular fault
um
and uh and then we observed a bit that
didn't matter
as far as being able to multiply
everything correctly
now the
the uh
the the general
then you could find an optimum solution
if we had a nice uh subroutine that you
could call would take any matrix like
this and find the smallest number of
rows
so that the union of the rows contains
an x in every column that there's that
there's a an x anywhere
so so eliminating the column that had no
that had no x's in it at all then you
get a situation like that now the now i
i've chosen this smaller matrix just to
to indicate let's see if we can't find
at least for the half adder the the uh
the optimum solution the the very best
way to to cover all the faults
um
now and then just think about uh
some some some things that generalize
okay so what what's the first thing that
occurred to you if you were
if you were faced with this problem you
know it's a
it's a
prize contest in games magazine or
something like this
kathy what do you think
um
i guess the best the best way to start
to is to to um
if you if you can't cross if you you can
cut across the rows and see how many
faults you've taken by each five five
five five five five four
five
four four four okay so the ones
so you can you try putting in the one
that detects the most
and then okay
this is like this is a lot of the greedy
approach yeah we're trying to cover ten
things and
and we might as well choose one at the
beginning that covers five
then we're half done something right
okay
okay
and then you go and
then you don't consider your rows you've
you've covered now and you choose the
next element using the same okay so so
suppose we choose the for this one which
covers five then we have five others to
cover
um
which are all the which are easy to
characterize because they're all the uh
um the left ones we only consider the
ones we haven't got this one cover gets
all the stuck at once and so
and so now um
the other cases then
uh
it gives us a reduced matrix
but with five with five columns in it
and it looks
like this huh
i hope i did this right
we're taking the five the five remaining
columns and the
uh
i think we get a pattern something like
that
so we knew so we
so if if we chose
this one as our first
the first run then we'd have to then we
have five columns remaining to cover to
be covered
and this is um
one two three four five six seven so
this is
these are the
what did i do you got an x at the bottom
of the fourth column
and x at the
bottom of the fourth column in the new
table
you're missing the next this one
one two
four
okay so which so this guy's got to go in
here one two three here
yeah
okay
all right so we can't pick up the
remaining five with another
another swoop like that
next i'll check the column to see if
there is anyone with only one case so
there's a row uh method yeah so you
check the column and see if there's
anything that there's only one way to
cover it
and um
it's not so there aren't any there
aren't any unique uh ways to to cover
but that's another thing that you can
say that every column has to be covered
somehow if there's only one way to do it
then we might as well
force it in there well you might as well
take all those right at the beginning
you could have done that at the
beginning instead of we did
yeah you can all yeah right at every
step try to
try to do to uh
to to look for forced moves
because that will that will uh uh
certainly eliminate
backtracking
or or other things to try
okay so now um
but we don't have we have cases where
there's only two
that get that look at this column here
this column here we've got to choose
either either 101 or oh one one
i'm going to base on expression
you write a big long boolean expression
and just uh
and just uh
find the minimum term
momentum
um
that's right there's the uh
that's the
proof that it's that it can actually be
done not only in
you know that we can actually give an
upper bound for how long it would take
to find that it would be polynomial
in the exponent
yeah
um
okay now this is um there's something
not staring you staring in the face
though about this
okay
that i'm waiting for somebody to say ah
what about oh well you never take an
input for another input a substance
sub soon well that's even more general
and i was even expecting thank you we
went we went two steps um
subsumes means what it includes
everything the other one doesn't okay
yeah so are there any rows that dominate
another or subsume other rows
because if one if something covers uh
everything another row does then there's
no reason ever using the other
yeah these are these are equal and so we
can we can uh you know pick one and
throw away the other
and in general if you had if you had a
subset relation between any two rows you
could take away the smaller of the
of the two well since the greedy
algorithm will do that automatically the
greedy algorithm does that automatically
but
yeah
this one which is force this way we find
the force
this way we find the force move which we
didn't find otherwise yeah so so this
this tells us that that uh without
without you know loss of generality we
can put 0 1 1 into the into the set now
the greedy algorithm wouldn't have
picked that because it's the only one
left that has only four in it it's the
it's the one that you really other than
wouldn't pick but we know that
sooner or later we'd have to pick it
anyway um so we did uh so we do get a
reduced uh i won't bother recovering but
i always make a mistake
um
i'll put uh but but this this can be
done without losing generosity so we've
already
covered this fault
and this font
will you write it
one o with one or will also have the
same
okay
oh
which one i want to know
oh one o
and one
oh i want this one yeah that's true okay
so these are these were even true in the
beginning and after you cross out
columns uh uh some things
you know more more dominance or
sub-assumptions might occur
uh so uh let's uh cross out this guy too
okay
you